[Music]
you hung out with David Bowie once and I
haven't talked to you since he passed
away yeah I had the pleasure of
interviewing him a few times but you
don't really hang out with him for a
long time I well I was just on has to
know we want Dennis Miller and John
Lovitz and I were walking around after
the show middle of night and we're at
the Columbus cafe let's go and it was
emptying in the back was Mick Jagger and
David Bowie you know and we sat with him
and it was really cool and Jagger goes
you know we're quite famous and they
were letting they're smoking weed is
that okay to say or whatever this is a
long time ago you're talking and Bowie I
don't do a Bowie besides like it would
you fellas like to go dancing you know
David Bowie to us and Dennis is like
chrissakes of course from the ground
controller Uncle Fred Astaire over here
Brad Jones like I'd love it so we went
downtown and David Bowie we got in dance
floor and the three of us awkward and
Bowie did all these cool moves and he
taught us this kind of turn around 360
you know he taught you a turn around
yeah turn around move can we see it whoa
whoa I'd have to be on the hardwood
though kind of go down
that pig it's just sort of like yeah
like it's like you just plant one foot
and then you go like that
[Applause]
looks like bully was here for a second I
wasn't sure if I was looking at David
Bowie or you it was unbelievable I was I
was almost passing out with joy over the
ever the years you you got to meet just
about everybody is there one comedian
present company excluded who you've been
sort of awestruck like you just couldn't
believe their talent their ability well
I was a waiter at the Holiday Inn near
San Francisco and I waited on Richard
Pryor you waited on Richard Pryor huh I
I gave him a Denver omelet and after
that I came back and you know I took the
omelet and he said I'll never eat it
goes whoever made that omelet can suck
my
and I never knew whether that was a
positive or a negative
and then I ended up doing a movie with
Richard Pryor 12 years later and I
wanted to know I wanted to know what he
meant all those years so at lunch I had
a cheeseburger and I'm sitting next to
Richard Pryor and I go man is a
delicious cheeseburger whoever made this
cheeseburger can suck mine and he goes
you must love that cheeseburger
[Applause]
moving at the mall I've met them all and
I've met you
yeah I'll use a surprise mm a what I'm
prepared to do I do think that's that's
her Bernie get the jacket up that's all
I'm saying
you